tamedia plus grande qualité de chimène
c'est que chimène et
vraie personne gentille mais pas gentil
pour toi vous rendiez des gens ils sont
gentils sont bêtes c'est vrai aucun vis
j'y mets des lentilles mais c'est vrai
julien est une des premières artistes
voir la première artiste qui va ouvert
les bras aux conjurés le milieu donc
voila moi c'est surtout ça que
j'apprécie et j'apprécie chez elle
et puis assez des termes très vivant
lille et j'aime beaucoup ça aussi c'est
marrant on en parlait tout à l'heure
joséphine baker
ouais mal à laval à gérer mère teresa
j'ai toujours
et puis après ma mère forcément
ouais voilà toujours fait nos premiers
exemples les premières femmes qu'on
côtoie et les premières femmes femmes
o'neill qui nous inspire sont évidemment
souvent dans notre entourage
gilmer grave
je ne veux pas le regarder non mais jean
michel maire jean michel sidibé